[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils avançaient en soi des accents et les
mouvements d'autre que ferme est
effectivement d'éviter les coups et puis
de trouver à bonne distance ou pauvre a
déclenché ce contretemps plus tôt
[Musique]
bani yas s'est fait très vite sur l'eau
oui c'est pas son blanc seing pour de
bon c'était aux jeux me des bouchées
doubles comme vous savez je sais qu'en
font aussi rénové oui justement
j'aimerais parler justement c'est grâce
à la boxe je peux les faire vivre
c'est la ville très difficile alors si
jamais kim avait quelque chose en cours
de route mais je perdrais tout en
octobre 1968 j'ai parlé ami commun nous
suit la vie de madame paris là savent
eux qui étaient complètement et pleurer
et ne comprenait pas là les raisons pour
lesquelles la suite d'une simple
opération de décollement de rétine son
mari était décédé
incompréhensible et pu mourir de ce
décollement de rétine
c'est comme si c'était hier encore
comment on en a parlé cette semaine j 10
rester son chapeau en fait il a on on
soulève le chapeau pour faire sortir
tout ça et on repart les mains vides au
match de françois et de marcel cerdan
bon bah c'est un match aussi posé
beaucoup de questions ça fait un très
très beau combat très beau combat mais
je pas trouvé que françois avait sorti
ses tripes
toujours est il qu'après le match le
match trouvait dans les salles
[Musique]
tu as fini et qu'ils ont dit que si tu
es siad en cas de gagner je peux vous
dire
[Musique]
compliqué à l'aube à ce combat laisse
moi te conter l'histoire d'un petit noir
venu bouleverser la france a traversé
victoire c'est les années 60 et je te
prie de croire que de lancre a coulé
tout en gravant tes mémoires
c'est par sa passion qui l'a nourri ses
enfants en montant sur un ring on peut
jamais faire semblant il avait mis tout
son coeur dedans il n'a encore que 30
ans on lui enlève la vie subitement
c'est cet âge que moi j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est comme si je partais demain avant
d'avoir poussé mon dernier cri c'était
des palau aujourd'hui mangerait pas ici
comme si tout ça était décrit alors
c'est fièrement aujourd'hui je porte son
nom maman m'a dit tu n'es pas là par
hasard fiston jusqu'à ce jour j'essaie
d'en tirer des leçons de vie j'espère
jamais te décevoir car je sais que tu
suis de là
là haut
je
dollar
la roue
non
là haut
françois pas villa qui a été champion de
france de boxe qui a discuté des
championnats d'europe qui a aussi
disputé un championnat du monde
mais même s'il n'a pas été champion du
monde
c'est important parce que c'était le
petit martiniquais qui finalement avec
avec ses poings juste avec ses pauvres
qui réussissait à imposer un peu la
martinique sur la carte du monde soit
par villa
[Musique]